so bill and ted are coming back to
theaters in August and Bill and Ted face
the music
we had the teaser trailer yeah so the
third movie will come this comes 31
years after the original adventure in
Keanu Reeves revealed on Sunday today in
May 20 19 before he started to shoot the
movie that he's actually not even sure
what he got himself into so why did you
want to come back to that story all
these years later cuz the writers had a
good idea I don't know what it's gonna
be like to play it out all but yeah it's
gonna be like I have no idea scared
25 years ago you played a concert in
front of the entire
[Music]
one month ago you played in Barstow
California for 40 people most of them
were there for $2 taco night
Billington what have you got to say for
yourselves
he backslide to each other party on
dudes
you are supposed to unite the world and
pave reality as we know it
we've spent our whole life trying to
write the song that were unite the world
why can't we just go to the future when
we have written take it from ourselves
busy that's doing
how's that stealing if we're stealing it
from ourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
no way how'd you like our song it's a
little on the dark side but you know
that's cool okay so rumor says Keanu
deserves this and much more he's such a
humble kind guy Sean says John Doe
hasn't changed since then he looks
exactly the same
I believe this man is immortal octa says
I feel like we need a movie like Bill &
Ted three during these hard times that's
for sure well yeah you think this is
gonna work I love I love you which I
love the I was I was very fascinated
with this because the whole premise of
Bill and Ted was that they wrote the
perfect song and it was the song that
United the world but in the movies you
never got to hear that song what that
song was and now that this is the this
is the the premise for the for the film
but I will say this Graham I have yes
long ago I added Keanu Reeves to my list
of people like Halle Berry
who I need proof that they are not
aliens right because they neither of
them those two I would say Keanu Reeves
and Halle Berry are top of my list of
people who may actually be aliens and I
need proof right now looking at Keanu
Reeves in that clip that he is not in
fact an alien yeah like I want to know
can he was skincare routine like what's
he doing at home we need the answers
my feeling is like I'm definitely gonna
watch it I love pianos do I think it's
gonna go over well and you know the
critics community I don't think so
but I guess whatever I mean people are
just bored at home let's watch something
funny I don't think the elicits the
originals go but the originals were not
reviewed well so I don't I don't think
that they're I don't think like they're
ruining a good thing the world needs
some Bill and Ted right now and yeah it
is gonna be fun and absolutely Cano and
Alex look great I'm not saying that just
are these characters gonna work like
basically camels 55 Alex wonders 54 they
look great but I'm just saying it turns
the characters they're in their fifties
now like I think about Dumb and Dumber
or when that sequel happened that didn't
really work
so I'm just not sure these characters
are gonna work in this context to tell
us you could tell kion owns a little
stiff like we're not gonna get any
matrix body language in this film like
he's he's got a stiffness to him now
it's a little different little stoic
vibe so I don't know yeah I'll say
nostalgia is very big right now and also
so is Kia so is Keanu Reeves and you
know I think that you know are they
expecting this movie to do avatar
numbers no but I think that you combine
nostalgia with the sort of ride that
Keanu was had over the last couple of
years and you had to make this movie
yeah it's gonna be fine no matter what